JUDY FAN: RGS stands for
Resident Graduate Student.
We live in the dorms
with our advisees,
which is often shortened "zees."
We work together with the
RCAs, the Residential College
Advisers as well as the Peer
Academic Advisers, the PAAs,
to form these coherent
advising groups.
And we play the role
that's somewhere
in between upperclassmen
and faculty.
NATALIA CORDOVA: We organize
activities for them.
We give them food
a lot of times,
but also other fun activities.
XANDER SLASKI: So we've done
a bunch of outdoor activities.
So we did whitewater rafting.
We have done quite a few
local hikes in the area.
We've done rock climbing.
We've done bike trips and
all sorts of different things
like that.
ALEX PIOTROWSKI:
I feel like being
an RGS adds a whole new
dimension to my life,
whereas normally during the
day, I'm just doing my work,
focusing on my thesis.
It's nice to get to know people
who are doing something totally
different, be inspired
by younger students,
and hopefully, be able to
give back to the community
some of my experiences that
I've had being an older student.
JUDY FAN: For some who
are considering majors,
there are so many possible
majors, they can choose from.
Psychology or neuroscience
may be among them.
Some will come to me and
ask about whether it's
a good idea, what classes
tney should be taking,
or how they can get
involved in research.
Those are all things
I'm super excited to be
able to talk about,
and share with them,
and help them navigate
all those choices.
BRENNAN MCDAVID: Now that I've
been here for several months,
I've realized that the
greatest value that I've
derived from being
here is the ability
to see a side of
Princeton that is
otherwise unaccessible
to graduate students.
I really feel like I understand
why the undergraduates come
back to reunions year in year
until they're 70 years old.
Now I really
understand why they're
so passionate about the school.
I'm becoming increasingly
passionate about Princeton.
SIMON CULLEN: I think my
favorite thing about it
has been just getting to
know the students-- not
a whole lot of them, but a
pretty good group of students
that I now consider my friends.
ADEDOYIN TERIBA:
Being an RGS has
been such a wonderful
experience that I
know that I want to
be a professor because
of the experience.
But I don't think
I would have had
the love I have for
the teaching profession
without the Resident
Graduate Student position.
So it has expanded my view.
And in a sense, I feel
like I am a born teacher.
I feel like being an RGS
has contributed to honing in
for me what I want to do.